Hãy bằng chứng vụ nhật bàn ngày 1 môn tâm mềm mô tổ chức của học các bộ trường đồng tiền để bàn về chính xe đối với người nước ngoài.
Một chứng những ước tiên hàng đầu của nguyên các mới, thu tướng tắc kỷ gí xa này, các hành vì phạm pháp của một số người nước ngoài đã gây lông hại trong sá hội,
phải yêu cầu ra soát toàn bộ cùng pháp liển anh.
Bà nhấn mạnh, chính phủ sẽ sửi nghiêm các trường hợp hi phạm, nhưng đồng thời không dung tổng chức các tự tự bàn ngoài.
Mò đam cân bằng giữa quả li ý và hội nhật, của học cũng thảo lần việc tăng cường giám sát sử đất đài của người nước ngoài,
cải thiện đu kiện sinh hoạt và ngâm trạm tình trạm lợi dụng chính xe đỉ nào.
Số liệu mời nhất cho thấy văn hiện có gân bốn chụng người nước ngoài của chú hợp pháp,
mức cao nhất tự trứ tỉ này, cho bối cảnh sá hội nhật bà ngay với trực bà ninh công cầu,
chính phủ hổng tổng tổng tự bột tiêu cân bằng giữa kiểm soát và hội nhật.
Bởi vì tụi hôm nhật, bởi vì chiều lịch sà hội và tăng trực kinh tế.